the thing that almost always happens is
they have this long to-do list and they
say all right here's what I want you to
do take everything on this to-do list
with the dates that you think they'll
get done by which is usually this week
or next week and I want you to just put
them on your calendar with the amount of
time you think it's going to take and
then we'll have another follow-up call
next week and we'll see what happens
and then we have the call and then they
say this process doesn't work they say
why is that so while I tried to move it
over there but there isn't enough space
in my week to fit all these items it's
like
yes that's that's the point this is the
point of the exercise is there literally
is not enough time
your time is finite and the number of
digital items you can add to a to-do
list is infinite you're you are working
with the wrong constraint which is like
the amount of items you can fit in a
database row as opposed to the number of
things that you can fit in your finite
time of your calendar and so we then
work on all right you probably need
slack during the course of the day
usually like 50 is a good Target because
things honestly not the tool slack but
yeah but space extra space you need
extra space in the day and so we work on
things like
for me I process a lot of email I
probably do and when you say you need
space in the day can you just briefly
say more about that because the way I'm
hearing that is that you have 50 of your
time
open oh but I'm not sure if
now is that
for instance like tomorrow you would
have 50 of your time open or does that
mean that in advance of scheduling other
things like three weeks from now each
day is 50 open it's generally 50 open so
fully got it and as you get better at it
I would say I'm probably at 25 open
because I've been doing this for many
years at least five years probably
longer to the point where I can I can
estimate how long it will take me to do
something with maybe 90 accuracy it's
like I need to write a memo on this
thing it's going to take me three and a
half hours and I just know because I've
written so many of these I just know how
long it's going to take right it takes
time to hone that I would think right if
you ask most people like how many
calories do you eat at lunch they'll be
like six thousand million I don't know
that's right seven galleries but then
over time you can calibrate okay
especially if you retroactively update
your calendar as well which is how long
did it actually take me and when you
realize that your estimates were off or
they were they were right you can start
to hone that skill so I always try to
have people put it at 50 open space
because something's going to come up a
friend calls you something thing happens
during the day you get a message that
kind of throws you off the problem is
that it's way easier to pull something
in from Tomorrow into today because you
had extra space than it is to have this
cascading problem of just like
disastrous it's like then I have to push
this to this day then next thing you
know like you have this Tetris game that
you're playing a month out because one
thing changed in your schedule
everything breaks these Concepts come
from manufacturing where you have this
line whatever the assembly line is you
need to have slack in the system in
order to be able to operate effectively
because something will come up and if
there's one thing that comes up that
breaks everything Downstream that's a
real problem and over time as you get
better you can reduce that amount of
slack but 50 is a pretty good goal so
you have like my goal for today I'm
gonna have a four hour block where I'm
gonna do X and then I have some time for
me I I know I need to process email or
Communications broadly for at least two
hours a day so I just have those blocks
every day they're just repeated so when
I start scheduling things it's like well
I can't actually fit this in because
it's not like I can't do my email this
is my role requires a lot of email and
so it's just clear as day I cannot do
this on Thursday
I can do it next week from a process
perspective then do you start with
imagining not at this point but just
just so I get a really clear
understanding let's just say you're
looking at next week you have these
recurring blocks of email that's already
in there you may have other repeating
blocks and I would be curious to know
what they are so let's bookmark that
when you're looking at say
the to-do's that will be converted into
calendar or not for the next week
what is that
process look like do you start with
maybe a a to-do list and then that goes
to your EA and she tries to slot he or
she tries to slot them in for the
anticipated amount of time like what
what does that look like from kind of
start to finish the answer is you just
skip the to-do list step entirely so
when I get a new task a lot of my tasks
effectively come in through email right
so I'll get an email and this is also
another thing that I I worked with a
couple people on who really really
struggled with email and
the thing they struggle with is using
their email as a to-do list which is a
very common thing that people do the
problem it creates a lot of anxiety when
you have this stack of uncategorized
things it could be 15 minutes it could
be 50 hours you have no idea until you
open up each one individually to figure
out how much work it is and so the same
process of translating your to-do list
into your calendar you can do the same
thing with email which is I work with
somebody recently where I said all right
let's open each email
how long is this going to take you to
respond to these are like the chunkier
ones it's like 30 minutes great Market
is done
copy the link and put that link in your
calendar so you're going to spend this
30 minute block responding to this email
what's the next one that's going to take
me a full hour because I have to write
something for them that's interesting so
the clearing of the inbox then is really
in some capacity scheduling yeah the
proper amount of time to reply to these
things so you're not looking at this
undifferentiated stack of exactly
that you are opening multiple times
marking is unread going back to
forgetting what you read reading at the
17th time or whatever that might be it's
a stress thing like it is very stressful
to have this list of things it's just an
ambiguous amount of effort it is stress
relieving to see all right I will do
that on Thursday of next week and I have
nothing I have nothing pending right now
I have not dropped any balls because I
know that anything that is time
sensitive that needed to be done today
is already done and there's nothing
there's no ambiguous deadlines looming
that I'm not aware of because they're in
my calendar and if you change it this is
where closing the loop is a helpful
factor which is if you say I'm going to
block this off for Thursday you can tell
that person hey I'll get back to you on
Thursday and then if you have to move it
you now know that you can say hey
something came up I'll get it to you on
Monday
and you can just keep them in the loop
on that as opposed to just Ambiguously
dropping the ball so
for me when I get a new task it just
immediately goes into my calendar so if
somebody was to say hey can you write a
memo on this topic so that this team has
context on it of where this has gone
over the last year I'll say sure how
soon do you need it say can you have it
to me by Wednesday I'll go to my
calendar and I'll block off two hours
because I think that's about how long
it'll take I'll block off two hours on
Tuesday that I have open and I'll say
cool I'll have a two by Tuesday night
and that's it the calendar is the to-do
list